merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre de la transition écologique
j'associe à ma question mes collègues
des circonscriptions concernées après
les codes du Finistère en décembre après
celle de la Vendée début janvier c'est
désormais les rivages de la
Loire-Atlantique qui sont souillés par
des vagues de billes de plastique cette
pollution est catastrophique et
irréversible par millions les billes de
plastique envahissent les zones
littorales rendant leur nettoyage
tellement fastidieux qu'il en devient
impossible les dégâts de cette pollution
sont considérables pour la biodiversité
marine poisson et oiseaux ingèrent ces
microbilles qui confondent avec leur
nourriture au-delà de la faune marine la
pollution va impacter le tourisme et
l'économie locale sans parler des
impacts encore méconnus de la présence
de ces microplastiques sur le long terme
pour les milieux et pour la chaîne
trophique marine la situation provoque
une émotion légitime les maires des
Sables-d'Olonne et de Pornic suivi par
la présidente de la région des Pays de
la Loire emporté plein de contrix
plusieurs associations ont également
saisi la justice aux côtés des élus et
des associations l'État lui-même décidé
de porter plainte monsieur le ministre
comment envisagez-vous de mobiliser vos
services scientifiques et techniques
afin de mener les investigations
indispensables pour identifier la source
de la pollution et ses responsables
l'arrivée des billes de plastique sur
nos côtes démontrent que le programme
volontaire cleanweep porté par
l'industrie plastique pour éviter les
pertes de ses bides à l'environnement
est insuffisant la législation doit être
renforcée la loi Haget de 2020 impose
aux entreprises les obligations pour
éviter les pertes de billes de plastique
dans l'environnement monsieur le
ministre des moyens de contrôle ont-ils
été mis en place pour s'assurer de
l'application de ce que nous avons voté
dans cette hémicycle la pollution marine
par les billes de plastique est un
phénomène mondial
qui impose une prise de conscience
internationale monsieur le ministre
envisagez-vous de porter la voix de la
France sur ce sujet lors de la deuxième
session des négociations du traité
international sur la pollution plastique
qui serait qui se déroulera à Paris au
printemps 2023